hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about two different kinds of
disease vectors that is biological
vectors and mechanical actors and then
excuse me so let's get started first
we're talking about what a vector is
well a vector is an animal that carries
a disease from host to host so carries a
pathogen from one host to the next host
please do not confuse this with vehicle
transmission they are not the same
vehicle transmission is when something
nonliving like food or water or air
takes a pathogen from one host to
another we're talking about vectors
we're talking about living animals now
talk about those two different kinds so
an animal that carries a pathogen from
host to host without being infected
itself is called a mechanical vector a
great example of this is the house fly
the house fly is thought to be able to
transmit as many as 60 Plus diseases the
way it does this is because it can land
on something like feces animal feces
human feces and then they can land on
your food and thus it deposits pathogens
from the feces onto your food that you
then ingest some diseases that spread
this way include cholera typhoid fever
even polio know that this can be
bacterial diseases like cholera and
typhoid fever love caused by bacteria
polio is caused by a virus so bacteria
are not the only kind of pathogens that
can be carried from person to person by
something like a housefly and so this is
that example of the mechanical vector
because the fly itself is not being
infected with these pathogens
it's just picking some up and some on
some fecal matter and that attaches to
its legs and it's depositing that Beagle
matter onto somebody's to so that's
mechanical vector an animal that carries
a pathogen that reproduces and
sign it before being transmitted to
another host typically via a byte is
known as a biological vector so again
the important part here and what makes
it a biological vector rather than a
mechanical vector is this part right
here the fact that the animal is
carrying a pathogen and the path video
is actually replicating inside the
animal although it may not cause disease
or any symptoms for that animal but it
replicates inside it and then the the
animal vector then transmits it to
another host and like I said usually but
not always through a bite some examples
of biological vectors include mosquitoes
mosquitoes through their bites can
transmit a wide range of pathogens
including those that cause malaria and
Iike yellow fever dengue fever the last
three are viral diseases the first one
is protozoan disease also things like
ticks ticks are biological vectors that
can transmit Lyme disease or likio says
Rocky Mountain spotted fever fleas can
transmit plague and so you see that most
vectors so the mosquitoes the ticks the
fleas the Flies most vectors that carry
human disease from one person to another
are arthropods
so Arthur parking enzymes however are
not every vector is an arthropod and
some examples of other vectors would be
dogs and other animals that can transmit
rabies these are biological vectors
because the dog or the other animals
that transmit the rabies are infected
with the rabies virus themselves but of
course dogs and others are the
vertebrate animals are
our thoughts another example of a fungal
disease that can be transmitted through
a biological vector is something like
ringworm
so people can actually get ringworms
caused by fungus from their pets and so
that wraps it up for today if you're
interested in these topics that have to
do with disease and epidemiology please
see my playlist it has lots of videos on
diseases and epidemiology content so for
example different kinds of pathogen life
cycles as well as things like cooks
postulates which talks about how you
figure out which pathogenic causes which
disease so be sure to check that out and
that's it for today thanks for watching
a biology professor